I grew up in the suburbs of Chicago
which was a wonderful liberal bubble
then I moved to Tennessee for college
after that I moved to Texas for my first
job I met people who grew up shooting
guns with their grandfathers people who
had strong religious convictions about
abortion and gay marriage if I'm being
totally honest the whole thing stressed
me out
I knew we disagreed about so many things
but I didn't want to bring them up I was
worried I might offend someone that I
might get labeled as intense or that I
might end up in one of those politically
correct agree to disagree situations
that everyone hates and I don't think
I'm alone for most of us talking about
politics is stressful and awkward and if
it's not it's probably because you're
only talking to people who agree with
you so what I want to do today is talk
about talking about politics why we
don't why we should and most importantly
how we can do it better so why don't we
like talking about politics for one
thing we're taught from a very young age
that the topic is just rude right just
like money or religion I'm not supposed
to know your salary question your belief
in God or ask who you voted for and then
even when we do start to talk about
politics we usually don't think we're
gonna change anybody's mind it's not
that often that we convince somebody to
change a really deep-seated political
view even more fundamentally when we
talk about politics we often feel
insecure and defensive have you ever
worried that so
might think you're uninformed that you
might get judged for a controversial
opinion research shows that when people
are shown information that contradicts
their political views the parts of their
brain that light up are those associated
with personal identity emotion threat
response in other words we feel insecure
and defensive because we're literally
wired to view attacks on our political
beliefs as attacks on ourselves so we're
conditioned to believe the topic is
Reard we don't think we're gonna change
anybody's mind and we feel insecure and
defensive so then why should we talk
about politics isn't it easier to just
leave it to the Talking Heads on CNN I
actually think that talking about
politics
sharpens our thinking when I spoke to my
conservative friends in Tennessee in
Texas I realized that a lot of things I
think the government should do actually
cost a whole lot of money sharing our
beliefs helps us challenge crystallize
reassess what we believe we start
recognizing trade-offs and our views
become more nuanced and hey if anyone is
going to change your mind about
something it's probably not going to be
Anderson Cooper
despite that persuasive jawline I wish I
had it's going to be your friends
neighbors co-workers classmates people
you trust and that you can have an
actual conversation with even more
importantly though talking about
politics helps us share ourselves with
the world we aren't born with any set of
political beliefs the issues we care
most about come from our most meaningful
experiences for me I think about the day
a close friend in high school came out
to me that was the day that gay rights
became
personal I think about the incredible
public school teachers who are literally
the reason I'm at Stanford today why I
care so much about investing in public
education I think about my parents who
came to this country from India with
nothing in their pockets to give their
children to give me a better life it's
why I think immigrants should be
celebrated not vilified this is the
stuff that makes you you
in the real you the you that is human in
the most beautiful and authentic and
wonderful of ways is too valuable in too
precious to leave locked up inside so we
need to talk about politics more and we
need to talk about politics better and
so here are the five most practical
things I can tell you about how to do
that first come from a place of
curiosity not offense or defense I know
that sounds like Tom Brady started
reading fortune cookies so let me give
you an example when I was in college I
moderated a debate between the College
Democrats and the College Republicans it
actually went really well and so
naturally I was walking around
afterwards being like move over Tom
Brokaw because there is a new face of
NBC but the woman who was organizing the
debate ran up to me furious she made me
watch the video when the Democrat was
speaking I was nodding and smiling
uncontrollably I literally looked like a
bobble head when the Republican was
speaking I just looked angry
I was not coming from a place of
curiosity I was coming from a place of
offense and defense
I just wanted my team to win and as a
result missed out on the opportunity to
learn something second pick the right
time in place discussions about politics
can be really difficult when there is an
audience watching whether that's a real
audience around a dinner table or a
virtual audience on Facebook try waiting
for a more intimate opportunity to talk
to someone like over an over a cup of
coffee as one mediation expert puts it
don't always stand up to those who
different beliefs instead try sitting
down with them three focus on one topic
at a time don't attack the entire
democratic or Republican Party or
everything the person has believed in
their entire lives that's when we feel
most defensive and insecure by focusing
on one topic we can actually accomplish
something over the course of a single
conversation fourth listen actively use
body language that shows you're paying
attention ask questions paraphrase to
verify you understand what they're
talking about most people need to feel
like they've been heard before they'll
listen to someone else or consider
changing their minds fifth and finally
avoid verbal attacks and obviously don't
hit anybody even if we're not usually
ones to lose control it's shocking how
quickly our language can change when
we're talking about things we really
care about language that's zero-sum or
that frames things in terms of good and
evil can kill productive dialogue so
let's review come from a place of
curiosity pick the right time and place
focus on one topic at a time listen
actively
and avoid attacks I know that's actually
a lot to remember I don't have a cute
acronym for you to take home and hold
your gasps but I broke the magic rule of
three but that's kind of the point of
course it's not going to be easy we're
talking about unlearning what we've been
taught our entire lives rewiring a part
of our brain and just like always
talking about politics is sometimes
going to be stressful awkward you name
it but I'll tell you something the
conversations I had over six years of
living in the south have made me a
better friend a better leader and a
better American so let's stop taking the
easy way out let's embrace discomfort
and let's start talking about the things
that really matter
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]